this isn't just a busking session
it's a test with a typically german
outcome
hardly anyone stops to listen rosa stark
knows that it doesn't have to be like
that
when she lived in california she noticed
that passersby responded with a lot more
enthusiasm
it's a big deal if someone stops and
says something nice it happens maybe
once an hour
what was it like in california um
there someone stopped every minute and a
half to say thank you for playing
one guy said i'd saved his evening which
hadn't gone well
i was really moved by that and went home
happy
people often thanked me or told me they
like the way i play
those experiences inspired her to start
her blog
a compliment a day since she's kept the
blog
she spreads compliments and appreciation
as well as a good mood
compliments are rare in germany so
people are even happier to get them
this young woman on the subway was
complimented on her beauty
her music teacher was praised for
believing in her
this couple for their outfits and this
kiosk owner for his impressive beard
i learned a lot i experienced so much i
heard so many stories and made so many
friends i wouldn't have met otherwise
that changed my life
i've also changed in that i now know
that even in germany if i'm willing to
approach people
it's worth it it's always ended up being
a very cool encounter
in major ways of course and italian has
a very different attitude towards
compliments than a scandinavian
who's going to be more reserved but
quite sincerely
an italian or a greek or a latin
american sees it differently
for them
in the meantime rosa stark is always
looking for ways to say something nice
to someone
it makes her happy too she takes the
nicest compliment with the best story
and posts them on her blog along with a
photo
she finds giving compliments easy now
but our reporter doesn't but she
definitely wanted to give it a try
any tips um yeah yes
it doesn't matter if you think the
compliment is really great or not you
just have to mean it
don't overthink it thank you
so with a hidden camera she set off on
her mission
it's not easy at first hello
hi do you speak english yes yes
i just wanted to say i like this one i
like your coat
thank you i just gave my first
compliment
the floodgates open i just wanted to
tell you
um you look great i like your cup thank
you
that's really nice it looks funny i
appreciate it
it's very nice i like your outfit
thank you complimenting cheerful
tourists is no
problem it's harder in a typically
german pedestrian zone where spontaneous
compliments are rather exotic
you two as a couple look very easygoing
and likable
you have a great smile
i'd like to compliment your mother for
the fact that you were so helpful to her
she raised her son well may i give you a
compliment
no no compliment no
i just wanted to say something nice i
think the color of your pants is great
it's good isn't it very cool
our culture of compliments isn't as
developed as it is in southern europe
but we do know how to complement people
for a lot of germans their reticence
means that when they do give a
compliment
they mean it sincerely
rosa stark appraises the day's
compliments for her blog
her choice is us the team from deutsche
weller
thank you it turns out that when you
give a compliment
you're likely to get one back in return